I've been a little disturbed about a
wave of cynicism that seemed to emerge
in the summer of 2010 at the time of the
10th anniversary of the original
announcement of a draft sequence of the
human genome there may have been those
who claimed that that draft sequence was
going to result in a complete
overturning of everything in clinical
medicine in the space of a year or two
but I don't think anybody who understood
the process of going from a basic
discovery to clinical implications would
have said those things and I certainly
hope I never did but ten years after the
fact it is fair to say that most of us
have probably not had obvious evidence
of a change in our medical care because
of the fact that genome sequence had
been derived certainly however if you
walk into a laboratory where people are
working on any aspect of human biology
it is utterly different now because of
the availability of that sequence and
graduate students can't even imagine how
anything was possible before that
information was accessible with a click
of a mouse so the scientific enterprise
is revolutionized the clinical
consequences are lagging behind but even
there I must say after sort of
encountering some of the cynical views
about the clinical benefits of genomics
I tried to sit down in a brief period
and just write down the things that I
thought had been significant as far as
implications that were already affecting
real people and there's a long list more
than two dozen examples came to mind in
the space of about ten minutes so while
they are for the most part applied to
relatively rare conditions if you're one
of the people with one of those rare
conditions they're pretty significant
personalized medicine is a term that
gets used differently by different
people in my view this is an effort to
try to take diagnosis prevention and
treatment and when possible factor into
that individual information about that
person in order to optimize the outcome
I think in some instances we're not very
far along with that and others we're
making real progress take for instance
the effort to try to choose the right
drug at the right dose for the right
person what we'd call pharmacogenomics
there are now more than ten percent of
fda-approved drugs that have some
mention in the label about the
importance of paying attention to
genetic differences in order to optimize
the outcome I'll take for instance the
drug aback of ear which is used to treat
hiv/aids a very powerful antiretroviral
but a drug that caused a pretty serious
hypersensitivity reaction in about six
or seven percent of those who took it we
now know exactly how to predict that on
the basis of a genetic test and so there
is now a what called black box label on
the FDA label for this drug saying you
must do that genetic test before you
prescribe this drug in order to avoid
that outcome that was unimaginable a few
years ago that you would have that kind
of precision in making that choice of a
drug therapeutics particularly in cancer
we're getting closer to the point where
somebody's tumor is going to be analyzed
routinely to look for a variety of
specific mutations that would predict
response to one of the new targeted
therapies as opposed to the broad-based
chemotherapy some people have compared
broad-based chemotherapy to trying to
turn off the lights in your kitchen by
nuking your house the idea is to try to
move more in the direction of turning
off the lights by flipping the switch
and that's what the targeted therapies
are aiming to do and you can point to
specific examples for people with lung
cancer or leukemia where that is a dream
that's not a pipe dream it's come true
for the
and they are benefiting hugely from this
kind of personalized approach to their
disease unfortunately that doesn't work
so far for the majority of cases where
we haven't yet found the Achilles heel
for the tumor to go after or we don't
yet have the right weapon to attack the
Achilles heel that we know is there but
it's coming